the following contains oilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys stammering you probably last
spoilers the last league photos in 2016
with my explanation of course in this
video I'm going to explain the meaning
of leaked photos of Sam Gilly and a
little salmon which they're leaving the
old town and also i'm going to explain
you the meaning or group which ian glenn
AKA Jorah Mormont christopher AK
atonement and joseph model known as
Benjen stark which was taken at
restaurant in belfast this let's call it
spoiler photos are most likely one of
the last photos of factors that those
filming location in Cyre we all can
expect a little slow down onto the
Christmas holidays pass at least until
the first week in the new year filming
has ended in Croatia with only few days
of filming if he didn't watch my
previous videos creation city dubrovnik
hosted Game of Thrones crew along with
you main actors such as Cersei Jamie and
the mountain along with extras who
depicted gold cloaks aka the city watch
and you search the screens guard with
stunning new armors by the way do brown
ink will represent parts of King's
Landing just like in previous seasons
game thrones crew mostly came back to
film a Dubrovnik because of World Poker
on which was in previous season film the
conversation between Tyrion and Varys
Jeremy Podesta has been in Dubrovnik as
well which plays those scenes most
probable in season 7 premiere as we know
that Podesta is directing season 7
premiere and finale first day of filming
in dubrovnik was at Fort boker on which
we've seen Cersei and Jaime along with
Jeremy Podesta and also along with
extras Lena Headey known as Cersei and
nikolaj coster-waldau known as Jamie
we're only presenting on the first day
of filming in dubrovnik while in few
other days of filming only director
jeremy police followed with filming crew
continued filming Jeremy Podesta
continue filming scenes added stone
steps of the mannequin monastery and by
the way the filming set didn't include
any actor those scenes only including
snow as a sign that winner has come even
to King's Landing this means that at the
end of the upcoming season we're going
to
witness coming of the true winner which
will come all the invade South meaning
that situation and winner file or at the
Castle black is far worse on the
shooting sat with so slow machinery
generated fake snow we can tell for sure
that those scenes are going to be scenes
of King's Landing not only because of
the fact that Dubrovnik has represented
mostly King's Landing through the
previous seasons but also because of
Lannister flags hanging on the walls
those scenes of Jaime and Cersei at Fort
Polk are going to be part of season 7
premiere those things of snow at King's
Landing are in my opinion definitely
going to be part of season 7 finale
mostly because of the fact that Jeremy
Podesta was present while filming those
scenes and also because of one other
fact which is while filming at fort
walker in richardson Jamie took their
part within see any snow machine or snow
which puts those several scenes film in
Dubrovnik into several different
episodes filming in Spain has also in a
few days ago with filming set accessory
filming in Spain ended it scenes which
included John Bradley aks ml thoroughly
and Hannah Murray known as Gilly as you
can see from leaked photos on a shooting
self-represented Sam Gilly and little
Sam and it seems that they were
preparing to leave and few months later
they actually left old town and were
heading somewhere most likely north on
the filming set was also spoiled
director Matt shackman which plays this
scene scene I'd repsol for or episode 5
while Sam and Gilly were leaving from
Lee photos we can see Bravo's girl near
Sam and Gilly at first look it's just a
little girl but could this little girl
be something more could it be one of the
Faceless Man assassins who is going
after Sam or even better question why
would someone want to kill Sam those are
the questions which I'm going to try to
solve in my future videos for now in my
mind is only Sam's father Randall from
whom Sam stole hearts bein the ancestral
Valyrian steel sword of house Tarly
which has been in the family for 500
years the thing that randyll Tarly would
pay high price the one of SS it's only
to bring back his Valyrian steel sword
let me know your opinion in comment
section down below these few months of
filming in Spain
I had to admit but a lot of leaked
photos to us with all spoilers from
filming sad maybe the most important
ones could be leaked photos from los
barcos ma party that accessory which
gave us a lot of spoilers particularly
it gave us leaked photos from huge
filming set in which we could see the
trike ambush and Leinster centaurs army
while they were marching home with
carriages full of good slowly from
Highgarden also from leaked photos with
odd result of the massive battle with
huge casualties for both sides along
with a lot of smoke which in our opinion
will the pic aftermath of drones
fire-breathing which means that Danny
writing drogon will come and help her
the draggy horde to win the battle while
leaked photos taken week ago give us
probably the biggest spoilers for the
upcoming season give a slave photos in
which we saw yours first appearance on
season 7 filming set along with Yara and
sand snakes it's not most likely the
theorem will pledge his are inflated
Circe in the upcoming season but in your
turn Cersei will have to marry him
similar deal as he had with Daenerys by
that time his siblings were faster as we
can see Yara Aleria in teen will be
captured after human destroys their
fleet and will parade through the
streets of King's Landing which could be
considered as the biggest boiler for the
upcoming season from leaked photos we
can see your own great joy on his horse
which is that taught in a Greyjoy
looking face plate linen yarn and chains
through the streets full of King's
Landing citizens who are welcoming their
new hero you're on Greyjoy Yara is not
the only one who is going to pray to the
streets of King's Landing they're also
captured delirious sand and her daughter
teen from leaked photos as you can see
there are missing a bar and Amelia these
two send snakes in our opinion and also
supported by Luke plot are going to die
during the battle fleet against Iran
actually I explain all of this in my
previous videos so if you want more
detailed information about it feel free
to check it out however with all those
exciting like photos or should I save it
all of these spoilers filming in Spain
has end a few days ago now let's get
into spoilers from Northern Ireland we
have already brought it here is
supported by Luke plot and leaked photos
image on
Jorah ginjury Davos few members of the
Brotherhood without banners and few
members of the Nights Watch will go
beyond the wall to capture white in
favor to prove the nearest and rest
Westeros that the true war is just about
to come theory also says that they're
going to be noticed by the night King
and later are going to be attacked by
his army on the icy surface which will
result with one member but Brotherhood
without banners getting killed while the
rest of John's team will be saved by
Danny and her dragons all except John
who is going to be surrounded by horde
of the undead army but then all of a
sudden benjin will appear and will save
his morning nephew with setting John his
horse while he's going to stay to fight
and die as a hero this Furyk has been
refused by so many fans but as time
passes more and more proofs are going in
favor to this theory firstly we witness
creating the new sad by Game of Thrones
crew at valle hill curry about Belfast
Game of Thrones crew has blanked the
area with fake snow and creating an
artificial ice surface rather like a
nice the lake along with a large green
screen with snowy ground beneath it
after that there are purely photos with
even harder proofs as in the first one
we can see the unit of whites in the
screw made set about Belfast which they
were preparing for a few weeks for the
shooting 300 experts had been brought on
this size is sad now this photo still
didn't cover much but then more like
photos came from Belfast with even more
proofs the second folder also goes in
favour to this theory as we can see
three main characters that have never
crossed paths in previous season but are
now together just like tea recess and
guess where are they Darren in Belfast
but in my opinion after the last photo
which was taken at restaurant in Belfast
which i'm going to show you again in a
few moments we can consider this year is
a confirmed one on this photo we can see
England known as Jorah Christopher Hill
junon is dormant ain't joseph mo known
as Benjen stark him great time at
restaurant let me repeat this to you
these characters have never crossed
their paths in previous seasons butter
now together in Belfast near filming
sad as a final confirmation kit
harington also appeared in Belfast as we
saw a lot of photos taken by fans
there's also only photo from Isis add in
our opinion is the photo Jon Snow as I
have already said in one of our previous
videos but since this photo quality is
way too low I cannot tell for sure if
it's John it could also be another
character as well now we're only waiting
for Emilia Clarke aka Daenerys to appear
on the size is set which we are
expecting to happen in 2017 as I said in
the beginning of this video these are
probably going to be lastly photos for
this year since all the actors are
having time off until probably the first
week of a new year we can expect to see
more like photos from filming set in
Belfast in the first few weeks of 2017
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and see in the next one piece
[Music]
you